sometimes watching a movie isn't enough
you also want to eat that movie that's
why there's movie recipes today we're
with Chef Dale levitski at cinema in
Nashville Tennessee
I colored cuisine eclectic American we
do a lot of I guess comfort based foods
but kind of like turn French classics
Italian classics American classics all
on their ear it's very familiar
ingredients just done in a very
different way we're not really going to
put many ingredients on the plate that
you haven't heard of or seen we have
challenged him with making a little
something inspired by none other than
the Little Mermaid
chef Levitsky has chosen a list of
essential ingredients The Little Mermaid
should consist of they are seaweed
because we're under the princi beef
tenderloin to represent the Hulk Ariel
Falls for octopus this is where Ursula
ended up and crap Oh Sebastian
it had been actually about 20 years yeah
since Disney had come out with a
traditionally animated film that
connected with audiences maybe the year
before they did Oliver and company yeah
and I think they had like stuff like
Great Mouse Detective well there was the
Black Cauldron when I was really on and
that didn't that wasn't a huge hit yeah
so Little Mermaid comes along and boom
everybody loves Disney animated movies
and then we start getting Aladdin Lion
King beating the Beast
Pocahontas all of that stuff and here we
are today and we're tired of all that
crap
so the songs are what I remember most
from this movie kiss the girl the one
that opens that part of your world now
you talked about this earlier where I
can't ever hear part of your world any
more without hearing Satan singing from
the South Park movie yeah it's such a
great parody of that
for unfortunate souls late loss on all
these classic songs that I remember in
high school in college everybody was
going around singing
story-wise what we have is a mermaid who
loses her voice and falls in love and do
they fall in love just because they
they're both hot because they don't do
much talking now yeah the boat she can't
speak that's pretty much the the the I
would say the theme of all Disney
romances is that they're both hot both
hot
therefore they never have anything in
common
Cinderella's that way for sure
Cinderella Snow White is like that I
mean it's no way I mean literally that
she not even longer yeah not even awake
this girl's hot I'm gonna kiss her yeah
that's it yeah that's like a predator
yeah yeah it really is
okay oh this looks pretty awesome and uh
oh oh and now you're making it better
oh and it's green it's a Little Mermaid
in a bowl Little Mermaid enroll so it's
kind of inspired by her little cavern of
things that she doesn't know what they
are all I'm very excited is there any
any particular order I'm supposed to eat
the thing no just every everybody'll be
different just go for it okay about this
yeah this I'm pretty sure is octopus
here yeah octopus and seaweed
this is a first onto two levels
well I'd octopus it's really good that's
pretty awesome yeah I like the broth too
with it
I'm gonna go broth only here that's a
lot better than I would have ever
thought seaweed broth would taste yeah
like there might be room for more
seaweed in my diet
that's a mate what's this little white
thing here
what are these white things dill lotus
root what is that loaded lotus roots
actually it's like a lily pad it's like
a flower though it's the root that is in
is in the water it smell like a water
chestnut in a way where so it's just
slightly just really mild in flavor kind
of crunchy I'm gonna ask a stupid
question is this is this part of it or
is it just decoration all right you can
totally dude you can you know pick alone
we do a fried one we do a raw one okay
the octopus was garnished though so I
hope you need that yeah that is
poisonous nobody said anything about
poisons thanks for watching today's
episode make sure you leave a comment
about what movies and ingredients we
should use in the future and if you want
to learn more about the chefs and the
dishes they created for us click over to
the community table channel and
subscribe